you know actually we were a very small
company when I came on the scene in 67
it's about two million dollars a year of
it where we work all western India
vegetable products limited at that time
we were in cooking fats crushing oil
seeds and we continued with that bridge
business but we moved it from being a
commodity business to being a branded
business in 76 IBM exited the country
and IBM had dominant market share in
information technology products in India
and we saw an opportunity coming up
there and we were looking for a high
tech diversification which had an
annuity service revenue so we put an act
together and launched a microprocessor
base multitasking multi used a computer
system in 1980 and it was immensely
successful because we invested a huge
amount in R&D a huge amount in software
services and software support services
and software solutions and there was no
looking back after that and then we
gradually grew that business to address
global customers and services at that
point of time we were quite a profitable
vegetable oil company and we had strong
reserves and therefore we were capable
of leveraging part of those reserves and
our equity to do some borrowing but we
started small but we were profitable
from from year one and we've clawed back
all our profits in terms of future
growth
we have recently used all the white
spaces of our businesses to launch a
business and eco energy where basically
we offer consultancy services to our
clients focus currently on India but
quickly on our large global clients
where we are able to analyze the energy
requirements tell them how they could
significantly save on it systems
integrated systems engineer a solution
implement that solution and maintain
that solution so it is going to
potentially be a very large business for
us going forward because we have a first
mover advantage in it
one most important it must be a business
which we can do ethically without
compromising on integrity some
businesses across the globe require too
much quid pro quos visib is being
successful in them and we're not willing
to do those quid pro quos which are
unethical second is a very clear
criteria that we must achieve leadership
in that business and when I say
leadership we must be in the top three
in that business in terms of market
positioning partnership with the
customer choice of the customer as well
as size and three it must be a business
which gives us annual T revenues which
are for recurring nature because that
gives stability to our company
well many years back many many years
back we into the financial services
business and we realized it was the
wrong business to get into
and we exited that business but we
fulfilled every commitment of ours to
our lenders and borrowers in that
business even though that cost us
substantially we also entered the
dot-com business at one stage with an
address to the consumer and we quickly
realize it's not a kind of business we
could make a long-term annuity out of
and we exited that business